i'm in barnsley right now these houses  are selling for about a hundred thousand  pounds however this house  my man pete just bought this hey how  much did you buy this house for 66 000.  he bought it for 66 000 pound how did he  get it so cheap because it worked due to  it absolutely but you you've done the  work how much do the work cost  600 600 pound for this wall  was 12 grand plus 12 grand for the  entire refurb he's made an extra room so  now he's four rooms he's not renting  this out to one tenant he's running this  out to four tenants room by room in  total per month how much are you getting  ready  [Music]  so he's renting this house out he's got  tenants moving in for 1500 pounds per  month and he bought the house for 66  grand  and now the house is worth how much  about 120. about 120 now he's  refinancing putting all his money back  out